c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
sont les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir les éléphants qui
s'inclinent face aux pharaons la côte
d'ivoire a perdu aux tirs au but face à
l'egypte en huitièmes de finale de la
can on fera le point sur cette rencontre
avec notre envoyé spécial au cameroun et
on ira aussi à abidjan où la grande
déception n'empêche pas les supporters
de faire la fête la tempête tropicale
ana s'est abattue sur madagascar le
mozambique et le malawi je vis dans
l'humain est provisoire au moins 47
personnes ont péri les dégâts matériels
sont aussi considérables on reviendra on
y reviendra dans cette édition et puis
ce geste d' emmanuel macron inverse les
pieds noirs les rapatriés d'algérie le
chef de l'état a reconnu la
responsabilité de la france dans la
fusillade de la rue d'isly survenu en
mars 62 une reconnaissance qui s'inscrit
dans la continuité des gestes des
manuels macro mais qui intervient en
pleine campagne présidentielle
décryptage dans un an
les éléphants de côte d'ivoire se sont
inclinés face aux pharaons d'égypte à
l'issue des tirs au but ont fait le
point avec notre envoyé spécial à douala
benoît paire o'shea
des joueurs ivoiriens a battu dans le
rond central à l'issue de ce huitième de
finale face à l'egypte c'est l'image
qu'on va retenir de cette soirée ici à
douala les éléphants qui quittent cette
coupe d'afrique des nations nous
laissant un sentiment mitigé séduisant
lors de la phase de groupe dégageant une
vraie force collective et bien ça n'a
pas du tout été le cas ce soir face à
l'egypte des ivoiriens désorganisés
après la sortie sur blessure du milieu
de terrain du milan ac franck est fier
malgré de nombreuses occasions l'egypte
ne va pas réussir à en profiter encore
beaucoup de maladresses et de manque de
réussite des attaquants égyptiens devant
le but ce soir les ivoiriens eux aussi
s'en procurer quelques opportunités mais
jamais ils n'ont réussi à imposer leur
rythme au cours de cette partie c'est
donc lors de la séance des tirs au but
que les deux équipes ont dû se
départager mohamed abbou gabelle qui
était entré à la 85e minute de jeu a
réussi à détourner le tir d'erik bailly
sur la barre transversale malheureux le
défenseur de manchester united qui est
réalisé pourtant une belle can jusque là
il y aura forcément et certainement de
la déception ce soir du côté d'abidjan
puisque c'est ivoiriens sont donc
éliminés en huitièmes de finale il n'y
aura pas de mondial non plus au qatar en
fin d'année avec peut-être des
répercussions au sein de cette sélection
ivoirienne dans les prochaines semaines
la route continue en revanche pour les
égyptiens qui retrouveront les lions de
l'atlas les marocains dimanche prochain
à yaoundé en quarts de finale en côte
d'ivoire les supporters sont partagés
entre déception d'avoir perdu et
satisfaction d'avoir montré une belle
équipe tout au long de la compétition
comme nous l'expliquent notre
correspondante à abidjan alain ferré
jeunes
le gros coup de massue pour les
éléphants ivoiriens et pour les
supporters aux ivoiriens la côte
d'ivoire qui était donc à l'heure de
cette grande rencontre face à l'egypte
et qui aura cru jusqu'à la dernière
minute à la victoire donc des éléphants
et vous l'avez dit on a entendu tout à
l'heure benoît l'expliqué un c'était un
long match difficile pour les ivoiriens
et c'est finalement la dernière étape
des tirs au but qui aura permis aux
pharaons de s'imposer et de se qualifier
pour les quarts de finale alors
évidemment ici depuis que le coup de
sifflet de fin de match a été donné est
bien là l'ambiance est morose les rues
de la ville se commence peu à peu à ceux
à se vider alors beaucoup de supporters
qui étaient survoltés plus tôt dans la
journée et bien été tout simplement est
dépité très déçu du résultat et puis sur
la toile et bien sûr les réseaux sociaux
et bien beaucoup de réactions depuis la
fin de ce match on a vu par exemple
certains internautes tout simplement
dénigrer cette victoire qu'ils estiment
à peine obtenu pas de quoi se vanter du
côté des pharaons pour beaucoup
d'internautes donc plutôt amer et puis
d'autres de l'autre côté des internautes
qui ont choisi plutôt de se concentrer
de se focaliser sur sur l'effort qui a
été accompli et qui ont choisi d'être
reconnaissant reconnaissant envers cette
sélection ivoirienne
des éléphants dont qui selon eux se sont
rabattus jusqu'à la dernière minute qui
aura tout donné et qui pour reprendre le
terme de certains internautes pourra
rentrer à la maison la tête haute ce
voile et on passe à la deuxième affiche
de ces huitièmes de finale entre le mali
et la guinée équatoriale après une
séance de tirs au but c'est finalement
la guinée équatoriale qui se qualifie
pour les quarts de finale 6 tirs au but
à 5 ces images des joueurs gabonais de
retour dans leur pays éliminé en
huitièmes de finale de la compétition
par les étalons du burkina faso les
panthères ont tout de même reçu un
accueil chaleureux près de 5000
supporters massés le long de l'aéroport
international de libreville ont tenu à
saluer leur performance hier soir on les
écoute suivi de la réaction de patrice
neveu le sélectionneur de l'équipe
dans mes bottes l'emmenant portière on a
vu des panthères sur le terrain on s'en
fait de résultats qu'au finish je pense
que pour beaucoup ici ont protesté trois
matches trois défaites et qui ressort de
là sans défaite au bout de 90 minutes je
pensais quand même pour une fois plus
leur dis merci on n'est pas sourd à
baltard mais souvent les pantalons dans
cette musique et aux autres ils ont fait
plaisir voilà pourquoi nous sommes là
surtout satisfait j'irai lui du
comportement des joueurs et l engagement
qui jouit à l'égard du drapeau et du
peuple on leur devait ça il fallait
absolument
renvoyer l'image d'une vraie image
patriotique de jeunes qui pratiquent ce
sport et qui sont là pour tout donner
sur une bonne compétition on va
s'arrêter un instant sur cette
bousculade qui a endeuillé la can la
confédération africaine de football
exige la mise en place une commission et
l'ouverture d'une enquête la bousculade
à l'entrée du grand stade au lait menée
de yaoundé a fait huit morts et une
quarantaine de blessés reportage de nos
correspondants
reclus dans sa maison d'un quartier de
yaoundé
rosalie est inconsolable depuis la
disparition de son époux louis 65 ans
ancien commercial à la retraite était
allé encourager l'équipe du cameroun
face aux comores lors des huitièmes de
finale de la can il a perdu la vie lors
d'une bousculade mortelle devant le
stade d'olympie le soir du 24 janvier
comme on peut le voir sur cette image
amateur
mon amie maud où
il est parti à ça au stade 7
il m'a enseigné le matin
j'ai vu
l'accident a fait plusieurs morts et des
dizaines de blessés des blessés pris en
charge dans plusieurs hôpitaux de
yaoundé comme celui ci quelques
kilomètres plus loin
dans les chambres le directeur pierre
fouda rend visite comme chaque jour
cette passion dont ses services occupent
le
continent
hors de danger mais pas encore remis du
traumatisme de cette bousculade
cette victime qui a requis l'anonymat se
souvient
j'étais fait le tram soulève désormais
de nombreuses interrogations notamment
sur la responsabilité de la sécurité à
l'entrée du stade de l'est mais un stade
autour duquel des camerounais comme
moussa viennent se recueillir lui a
perdu une amie il souhaite désormais que
justice soit faite
un champ
c'est un choc c'est qu'on a l'impression
qu'il y avait tous les moyens pour
éviter cela cette pas une fatalité
c'était pas quelque chose d'imprévisible
selon les autorités une enquête est en
cours pour établir les responsabilités
lors de la tragédie les matches de la
compétition dans le polémique stade de
limbé ont été suspendus jusqu'à nouvel
ordre par la caf
voilà pour l'actualité de l'as cannes
aujourd'hui le mozambique madagascar et
le malawi ont été balayées par la
tempête tropicale ana elle a déclenché
de violentes inondations des glissements
de terrain et des coupures d'électricité
sur la majeure partie des trois pays
pour l'instant le bilan fait état d'au
moins 47 morts lors envers stecher
essoufflé les yeux encore gonflés par
les larmes et l'épuisement merci jalil
ausy peine à se remettre de son
traumatisme
alors qu'elle traversait un pont
surplombant la rivière du scheer sa
voiture a été emportée par les eaux
après avoir traversé madagascar la
tempête tropicale ana s'est abattue
lundi sur l'afrique continentale au
malawi les crues ont entraîné
d'importantes coupures de courant et
partiellement détruit l'autoroute
principale du pays des dégâts qui ont
retardé les opérations de sauvetage
selon les autorités locales des
centaines de personnes pourraient se
retrouver piégées par la montée des eaux
[Musique]
la tempête and a également fait des
ravages à madagascar et au mozambique où
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
ont perdu leur logement dans des
glissements de terrain ces dernières
années les tempêtes et cyclones qui
s'abattent régulièrement sur le sud de
l'afrique ont gagné en intensité à cause
notamment du réchauffement climatique et
de la montée du niveau des eaux
les ministres des affaires étrangères du
mali de mauritanie du niger et du tchad
n'ont pas pu s'entendre sur la tenue
d'une réunion conjointe avec des
représentants de l'union européenne ce
mercredi à bruxelles c'est ce qu'a
déclaré le haut représentant de l'union
européenne pour les affaires extérieures
joseph bourrel par ailleurs sachez que
la cedeao va tenir un conseil
extraordinaire ce vendredi au sujet du
burkina faso et du mali la cedeao qui
condamne fermement le putsch au burkina
faso
vous le savez takouba cette coalition
des forces spéciales européennes voulue
par la france pour lutter contre les
djihadistes dans le sahel est dans le
collimateur de bamako les autorités
maliennes ont dénoncé lundi le
déploiement de troupes danoises dans le
cadre de cette force le premier ministre
de transition choguel maïga qui a
demandé au danemark de retirer ses
forces spéciales s'est expliqué on les
écoute
dano fanaf novak ana si vous voulez
venir au mali c'est un engagement entre
danois et maliens on n'acceptera plus
que quelqu'un vienne dans notre vie
surtout qu'ils disent qu'ils vont mettre
en place une force 10 d'attentes ils
viennent pourquoi est ce qu'ils ne
viennent pas préparé quelque chose qu'on
peut pays n'accepterons plus cela c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
demandé au delà de rentrer chez eux la
population où personne ne viendra plus
au mali par procuration avant ça se
faisait aujourd'hui ses films sous
l'autorité d'hassan higuita ça ne se
fera plus si grande est venu au mali on
doit se mettre d'accord là dessus
ce geste d' emmanuel macron à l'égard
des rapatriés d'algérie les pieds-noirs
le chef de l'état a reconnu la
responsabilité de la france dans la
fusillade redit ce nid c'était le 26
mars 1962 une semaine après la signature
des accords d'evian des dizaines de
personnes sorties manifester contre
l'indépendance de l'algérie sont tombés
sous les balles de l'armée française
alger 26 mars 1962 les accords d'evian
sont signés depuis une semaine la guerre
d'algérie est officiellement terminée
mais à l'appel de l'oas trente mille
partisans de l'algérie française
manifeste et tentent de forcer les
barrages installés par l'armée il arrive
au niveau de la rue d'isly
soudain une fusillade éclate
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'armée française tués au moins une
cinquantaine de personnes tout civil et
fait des centaines de blessés l'algérie
française vient d'avoir ses martyrs
l'armée française qui tirent sur des
français pour la première fois l'état
admet sa responsabilité
soixante ans après
la france reconnaît cette tragédie ce
massacre du 26 mars 1962
est impardonnable pour la république
impardonnable un mot d'apaisement
vis-à-vis des pieds noirs qui succède un
autre geste mémorielle il y a trois mois
emmanuel macron avait qualifié d'
inexcusable le massacre du 17 octobre 61
à paris contre des algériens ya quelque
chose du en même temps chers à notre
chef d'état il faut donc reconnaître
qu'il ya eu toutes sortes de groupes qui
ont souffert de cette période pour
essayer d'apaiser l'ensemble et en même
temps de faire en sorte qu' aucun groupe
ne se sentent oubliés ce soir marine le
pen dénonce ce qu'elle appelle le
clientélisme électoral du président pas
encore officiellement candidat à sa
réélection
une reconnaissance qui s'inscrit dans la
continuité des efforts mémorielle
entamée par emmanuel macron depuis son
élection le chef de l'état multiplie les
gestes de réconciliation avec l'algérie
avec les harkis également pour beaucoup
il manquait aussi cette reconnaissance à
l'égard des pieds noirs seulement ce
geste intervient en pleine campagne
présidentielle sur un des thèmes
privilégiés de l'extrême droite écoutez
l'analyse de karine et oui c'est vrai
que ça ne va pas forcément satisfaire
tout le monde d'ailleurs une association
de rapatrier importante n'a pas voulu
venir parce qu emmanuel macron en 2017
avait expliqué que la colonisation avait
été un crime contre l'humanité certains
vont dire qu'il s'adressait un électorat
à l'époque et qu'il s'adresse à notre
électorat aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il y à
un certain nombre de maires qui était
présent celui de montpellier ou encore
celui de béziers robert ménard dont on
connaît la position politique plutôt à
l'extrême droite en tout cas emmanuel
macron ce d'autres expliqueront qu'ils
de toujours lui aussi opérer un
rééquilibrage puisqu'il s'est adressé
dans un premier temps aux algériens aux
enfants d'algériens ont reconnaissant
l'implication de la france de la dans la
mort d'ali boumendjel cet avocat
nationaliste algérien ou encore en
s'arrêtant un instant sur le massacre du
17 octobre 1961 lorsque maurice papon a
fait jeter dans la seine des dizaines
d'algériens et on est finalement dans
une autre séquence où emmanuel macron
s'est adressée récemment aux harkis il
s'adresse désormais aux rapatriés
d'algérie mais évidemment en cette année
d'élection présidentielle beaucoup y
verront une manoeuvre politique ce que
du côté de l'elysée évidemment on
rejette en bloc voilà c'est la fin de
journal de l'afrique rester avec nous la
faut continuer sur france 24
[Musique]